bonjour et bienvenue sur france 24 sur
radio france internationale nous sommes
à l'union africaine à addis abeba est
notre invité le ministre des affaires
étrangères du maroc nasser bourita avec
moi pour cette interview florence
maurice de rfi
monsieur brut a le premier ministre
palestinien mohammed shtayyeh a déclaré
à la tribune a exhorté l'union africaine
a retiré le statut d'observateur à
israël on aimerait bien comprendre
exactement la position du maroc parce
qu'elle n'est pas très claire est ce que
vous êtes en faveur de ce statut
d'observateur est ce que vous comprenez
les critiques du premier ministre
palestinien à l'égard des pays notamment
arabes qui semble favorable à ce statut
d'observateur moussa faki était dans son
dans son mandat et je ne parle pas du
fond moi je parle d'abord de la
procédure
trois ou quatre pays ont annoncé chez
eux
qu'ils allaient combattre cette décision
ils sont venus à partir de cette
surenchère nationale pour imposer leur
position ici à l'union avril je pense là
aussi qu'il faut comprendre que l'une
africain a changé qui n'est plus la
chasse gardée d'un pays aux deux qui
peuvent dire non on va bloquer et que
l'organisation va les suivre
l'afrique a changé de nom africain n'a
changé et les débats non membres et il
se trouve aujourd'hui que 44 pays
africains ont des relations avec israël
44 je pensais et margaret thatcher qui
avait dit un jour sur le nu c'est le
miroir qui reflète une réalité si cette
réalité ne plaît pas quatre pays
il faut la changer d'abord sur le
terrain il y a un parmi les pays qui qui
sont les promoteurs de ce débat
qu'ils ont reçues il y a une semaine
l'ambassadeur d'israël et qui ont une
ambassade avec un drapeau d'israël qui
flottent je parle de l'afrique du sud
comment on peut accepter une réalité
chez soi et venir imposer le contraire
au niveau des lignes raffinées recrutent
je pense que c'est une c'est un réflexe
que l'union africaine est une chasse
gardée qu'on peut faire à l'union
africaine ce qu'on veut ce n'est plus le
cas tu vu vous êtes favorable à ce
statut d'observateur on peut le dire
c'est clairement ce que l'on est
favorable à la mise en oeuvre des textes
cette organisation certains considèrent
que si le maroc tient ce discours c'est
parce que votre pays au fonds privilégie
ces accords commerciaux et de défense
avec israël aujourd'hui sur la cause
palestinienne
c'est faux le maroc est engagé aux côtés
du peuple palestinien nous tous on est
pour une solution à deux états lorsqu'on
lorsqu'on est pour une solution à deux
états c'est qu'on doit reconnaître deux
états qui doivent vivre côte à côte dans
la paix et dans la quiétude c'est ça la
position du maroc et là là là
le rétablissement des relations avec
israël ne changera aucunement la
position du maroc sur la question
palestinienne est ce que votre
rapprochement avec israël les accords de
coopération que vous avez ne vous met
pas un peu en difficulté sur cette
question qui divise aujourd'hui un
éclair par rapport à ses positions
lorsqu on instrumentalise par les causes
des autres ça ne pose pas de
contradiction et le maroc souhaite
également que l'évolution de sa relation
avec avec israël puisse permettre la
réalisation des des droits du peuple
palestinien à avoir un état indépendant
l'algérie
vous accuse de coopérer militairement
avec israël pour l'intimider qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ces accusations
bon ça fait moi ça fait longtemps que
j'ai arrêté de suivre ce que dit
l'algérie ou la diplomatie algérienne
parce que je vois qu'il ya beaucoup de
contradictions beaucoup des choses si ma
mémoire est bonne lorsque l'algérie a
décidé de rompre les relations
il y avait six ou sept fois à sac passé
pas seulement cette question l'algérie a
évoqué le sahara l'algérie a évoqué la
guerre de 63 la gérer l'algérie avait
évoqué beaucoup de choses je pense que
c'était ta l'iran qui avait dit qu'on
c'est excessif c'est dedans lorsque
c'est excessif c'est devient
insignifiant et je pense que lorsqu'on
est dans l'excès on a plus d'impact
l'algérie a pris des positions
unilatérales
c'est son droit la démarche de sa
majesté le roi a été de ne pas
aller vers l' escalade de ne pas même
pas réagir à ces décisions unilatérales
et ça sera toujours votre position donc
l'algérie dans l'excellent excès ce qui
est excessif est insignifiant mais les
positions du maroc sont claires est ce
que pour vous l'hypothèse d'une
confrontation militaire directe entre
vos deux pays est envisageable
aujourd'hui exclue le maroc n'est pas
dans l'escalier le maroc ne suit pas
l'avenir et le maroc pense que la
confiance jamais la géographie mais le
maroc comme je l'aï dit
il à des marches de sa majesté le roi
ne pas aller dans la l'escalette et de
se concentrer sur ce qui nous unit parce
qu'ils surent nous disent unis alors au
sahara le cessez-le-feu qui était en
vigueur plus ou moins depuis 1991 a été
rompu il ya eu des affrontements
militaires est ce que on est dans une
situation de guerre de quasi guerre ou
est-ce que ça reste des petites
escarmouches à vos yeux militairement le
maroc et dans son territoire et le maroc
est dans sa légitime défense le maroc
n'a jamais cherché
la confrontation de maroc et pour
une solution dans le cadre des nations
unies de ce problème dans le cadre de
l'autonomie sous souveraineté marocaine
et ceux qui auraient rejeté les
résolutions du conseil de sécurité n'est
pas le maroc qui a sorti un communiqué
en octobre pour dire je rejette la
résolution adoptée par le conseil de
sécurité
c'est ce pays-là qui a officiellement
rejeté la volonté de la communauté
internationale à propos est-ce que
l'initiative de l'envoyé spécial des
nations unies
un avenir où est-ce que c'est mission
impossible on a le sentiment que la
situation est bloquée l'algérie reste
sur la même position à savoir des
négociations directes entre vous et le
polisario ce que vous refusez est ce
qu'on n'est pas dans une impasse il faut
pas mettre l'algérie le maroc sur un
pied d'égalité le banque est en ligne le
maroc est aligné sur la résolution du
conseil de sécurité
l'algérie ne veut pas cette résolution
d' oncle pour le maroc et les à l'aise
l'envoyé personnel à un mandat un cadre
d'action lui même dit qu'il travaille
pour les table ronde si l'algérie ne
veut pas si son problème mais ce que
vous pensez que ça va se débloquer
moi je pense que le en tout cas pour le
royaume du maroc il ya une volonté pour
trouver une solution dans le cadre de
l'initiative d'autonomie marocaine et
rien que l'initiative d'autonomie
marocaine
le cadre c'est un cadre des tables
rondes avec la participation de la
véritable parti à ce différend régional
dans ce couloir demandez à n'importe
quel diplomate le problème du sahara il
est entre qui et qui lorsqu'on est un
acteur de ce problème l avantage de
cette escalade algérienne ce que
l'algérie aujourd'hui à démontrer qu'il
est la véritable parti à ce problème
c'est dans la salle il n'y a que
l'algérie qui prend la parole sur ce
dossier je veux en venir au dossier
libyen
rapidement la communauté internationale
a pesé de tout son poids pour que des
élections se tiennent absolument le 24
décembre n'importe qui un minimum
informé savait que les conditions
n'étaient pas réunies que ça n'allait
pas arriver est ce que vous pensez que
la communauté internationale a eu tort
de pousser absolument à ces élections
dont on savait bien qu'elle n'allait pas
avoir lieu ce sont les libyens eux mêmes
qui ont choisi lors du dialogue de
genève le 24 décembre ils ont mis les
institutions et les processus pour ça
tout le monde savait que ça n'allait pas
être facile
mais aujourd'hui au moins on a deux ou
trois avantages par rapport à la
situation antérieure
il y a un an et demi
tripoli était bombardée et on pensait
que la situation la solution ne pouvait
être que militaire en libye aujourd'hui
on voit que les gens sont en train de
débattre de la base constitutionnelle de
la loi électorale de la compagnie
comment la le cadre de la con électorale
donc déjà tout le monde à travers ce
processus des élections s'est inscrit
dans la démarche politique et tout le
monde s'est départi de la démarche
militaire deuxième acquis les obstacles
à la tenue des élections ont été
identifiés et aujourd'hui il faut
travailler pour dépasser à ces obstacles
et c'est ça le travail que le maroc
essaie de faire avec les différents
protagonistes libyens 3
les institutions ont montré leur utilité
le parlement le conseil d'état au
conseil présidentiel et le gouvernement
le maroc est contre le fait de créer un
vide en libye en dénigrant les
institutions quand les aime qu'on les
aime pas mais au moins aujourd'hui ces
institutions permettent à l'état libyen
de fond de continuer à fonctionner a
travaillé pour la préparation des
élections en travaillant sur celles qui
ont été identifiées à travers le
processus qui n'a pas été conclue le 24
décembre au delà de la question du
report des élections on voit bien que
les questions que ça soulève et dont
vous parlez exacerbe dans le pays un
certain nombre de tensions est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il va falloir encore que la
perspective d'une élection s'est éloigné
fortement pour longtemps je pense qu il
qu'il y avait il ya aussi une une
perception oro centric qui fait de
l'élection le
panacée pour résoudre dos le contexte
libyen le est un est un contexte
particulier l'objectif c'est de régler
la question de la légitimité mais sans
perdre la stabilité de la libye c'est
pour cela qu'il faut cet équilibre
comment avancer vers les élections mais
sans créer le chaos et la démarche du
maroc a été toujours une démarche
réaliste et pragmatique qui
responsabilise d'abord les acteurs
libyens on peut avoir tout les organiser
toutes les conférences internationales
en europe et ailleurs et établir des
recettes mais ce que ces recettes 100
adapté au contexte libyen c'est ça le
véritable problème aujourd'hui les
élections reste un objectif je pense aux
lib et le maroc y croit mais pas une fin
on a une fin en soi parce que le plus
important c'est que ce pays retrouve sa
stabilité retrouve son rôle parce que
pour le maroc comme l'a dit sa majesté
le roi la libye on n'est pas voisins
mais la libé très proche parce que sa
stabilité ne touche son instabilité nous
touchent et les liens entre les deux
pays sont très importants ils sont
présents siens le seul ministre merci
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi sur nos
deux antennes rfi et france 24 merci
[Musique]